despite mostly positive reviews
Vanquish is a game that few people
bought not even in its home country of
Japan and yet the game has a dedicated
group of fans that champion it as a lost
classic it seems Sega has finally heard
their cries because vanquish has been
given an honest-to-god PC port available
today which means the game now has the
second chance it deserves to impress all
the people that pass by the first time
along with any newcomers enough I go so
why is vanquish so beloved at face value
it's a third-person cover based shooter
with a muted color palette that came out
during a time when the market was
oversaturated with these kinds of games
and being created by a Japanese
developer some saw as an example of a
studio westernizing to appeal to a
larger audience but the reality is that
vanquish is a game that uses the
framework of a cover based shooter
something that everyone is familiar with
as a Trojan horse for its own unique
take on the genre
all clear
this game is a collaboration between
Shinji Mikami best known for Resident
Evil and Platinum Games the studio
behind Bayonetta and that's really the
best way to describe this game you have
a shooter that blends its mechanics with
the sensibilities of a character action
game the fluid chaining of movements
together to avoid damage while also
dishing it out yourself and the
all-important scoring system you can try
and play vanquish like Gears of War
sitting behind chest I cover popping out
to shoot some dudes and get some head
shots but it's far more exhilarating
when you take the game's two main
mechanics the rocket slide and the
time-slowing
a are mode and begin to combine them in
all sorts of ways hop over cover and go
into AR mode to get that guy you
couldn't hit before rocket slide around
the field to flank a boss
throw a grenade and then slow down to
shoot it at just the right moment and
then try using your rockets to but slide
into a robot kick him in the face
and then you shoot them when you begin
to take advantage of everything you have
available you really start to take in
the spectacle and how it just never
slows down
vanquish is a game where you feel cool
playing it
enemy transport should mirror your
position
and while Vanquish is a top-notch
experience to play it's wrapped in a
narrative that I can only describe as
wonderful Japanese b-tier Kitsch eyes
must be looking to get swatted Bravo and
recycling
the story involves Russians and their
army of robots capturing a massive Space
Station colony and using it solar energy
as a makeshift weapon to fry America
cities so the President of the United
States sends in a task force of Marines
along with protagonist and Solid Snake
wannabe Sam Gideon to stop them
Sam is equipped with the augmented
reality suit which is what allows him to
but slide to his heart's content all of
this happens within the first 10 minutes
which may seem like a lot but the
majority of the game is a simplistic
trek through the station from one set
piece to the next with plenty of
action-packed cutscenes and cheesy
dialogue reminiscent of 80s action
movies the two characters who talked the
most Sam and Lieutenant Colonel Robert
Burns spend the whole time trying to out
gravel eachother
vanquishes tongue-in-cheek nature was
really a wonderful contrast at the time
to all the games that took their stories
very seriously getting good at this
falling out of transports thing don't
you think
more like getting good and looking like
an [ __ ] Vanquish comes with a style
that sounds really dumb on paper but the
best kind of over top in its execution
the rocket-powered butt slide is the
most obvious example of its quirky
personality but subtle stuff as well
like the way your gun transforms or a
button that lets you smoke a cigarette
and that cigarette actually becomes an
important tactical option in later
difficulties because it draws enemy fire
away from you it's stuff like this that
makes vanquish so beloved it represents
a type of Japanese v game that had been
slowly dying during this time to see it
so poorly meant games like vanquish
would become more of a rarity which is
why it's so exciting that the game has
been given a second chance on Steam
while the port may not be a true
remaster being able to experience
vanquish past its original 30fps limit
at a now unlocked framerate only
increases the sense of chaotic speed and
allows for better handling and precision
Vanquish was never going to take the
world by storm when it first came out
but now in 2017 speed and mobility in
first-person shooters is back with games
like titanfall - combining wall running
and fast gunplay to make an exhilarating
game and vanquishes slide and shoot
style fits right at home as a third
person shooter equivalent it's really
telling how much vanquish was ahead of
its time in that in the seven years
since its release its unique mobility
and breakneck pace has never really been
copied by other games which means it
holds up really well now is the perfect
time for vanquish to make the comeback
it deserves
[Music]